i have good days and bad days now that
i'm having to adjust to my
new life my new normal nene leakes is
opening up about her grief following the
death of her husband greg pushing
through
pushing
on instagram the real housewives of
atlanta star shared details about her
support system at home i have a whole
group of people that's coming to my
house every day doing different stuff
with me so trying to keep my mind off
you know
the events that recently happened love
you guys okay and
um
i'm pushing through i have good days and
bad days but um
yeah they say it's normal so
some days i'm up some lay them down nene
also shows off her newish hair color
going back to her signature bold blonde
is just one step in adjusting to her new
normal so i played in dark hair long
enough
now that i'm having to adjust to my
new life my new normal
um
i thought i'd go back on i normally
don't go to the salon i usually let
people come to my house
so today i decided to drive to the salon
and actually sit in the salon with other
women
um
and uh that was good to be around other
people so
yeah before signing off nene paid
tribute to her fans and supporters love
you guys thank you for all of the
condolences and all of the
sweet comments uh
thank you
greg died on september 1st after
battling colon cancer he was 66. i would
just like to say i love you so much a
celebration of life was held at nene's
leninity lounge in atlanta georgia last
week where several of her former bravo
castmates came together to pay their
respects among those in attendance lisa
wu phaedra parks marlow hampton portia
williams eva marcel and kenya moore
honestly he is one of the nicest men
i've ever met in my life
to be there was a no-brainer kenya
opened up to e.t about the touching
service
i was there to support you know
greg never ever treated me any
differently whether i was feuding with
nene or not and for that i respected him
so much and he was just a kind gentle
caring supportive man and she was really
lucky to have him i think it was
everything she probably wanted it to be
because people were happy and i think he
would have wanted people to be happy
because his life was so full and so
beautiful and he was such a great person
so um even though it was hard for me to
be there it seemed like she she got what
she wanted for people to smile and and i
think he would have been happy about
that i reached out to her when i first
heard that he was in not a good you know
situation um and she responded and i
appreciated that and then i did get the
invitation and sent her flowers before
that and
so um
you know i just want i want her to be
okay
you